au lendemain de la seconde guerre
mondiale sans remonter plus haut j'ai
parlé des trente glorieuses tout à
l'heure vous l'avez compris en lisant
mon livre je postule qu'il ya une sorte
de dr progressiste qui était l'ambiance
intellectuel politique culturelle même
économique général pendant les 30 et en
trente années qui ont suivi la seconde
guerre mondiale ensuite effectivement
vous avez mentionné de libéralisme nous
sommes entrés dans une ère libéral qui a
commencé à son tour à s'effondrer à
s'effriter à partir de 2005 2015 entre
le refus de la constitution européenne
par les grands de la mort de giscard
d'estaing récemment et le vote du break
site et nous sommes entrés dans une ère
plus qualifient de populiste et bien les
deux premières évidemment parle de de
l'inter de l'inter quelque chose et
d'une certaine façon c'est l'épuisement
de la solution internationaliste qui a
soulevé des espoirs considérable qui a
mobilisé à partir de 10 ans 1880 avec le
mouvement socialiste puis évidemment la
révolution russe de 1917 enfin celle
d'octobre parce qu'il faut quand même
pas oublier en oublie toujours celle de
février
bon ben c'est une autre affaire là c'est
vrai que une bonne partie de la planète
a été soulevée par un espoir
internationaliste et par ailleurs le
libéralisme a été soulevé et continue à
être soulevées par un mouvement qu'on
pourrait qualifier de mondialiste en
tous les cas à chaque fois qu'ils
disaient que la notion de nation était
on y revient toujours dépassé ou en p4
dépassable mais tout ça ça a justifié la
vie de millions voire de milliards de
gens ça ne veut pas dire que ce soit le
sens de l'histoire le sens de l'histoire
dans ma jeunesse c'était
l'internationalisme on a assisté à son
effondrement
[Musique]